miller y dio aprobada el parlamento de
australia dio luz verde del jueves a la
primera ley del mundo que exige el pago
de google y facebook por los contenidos
periodísticos que comparte una semana
después del bloqueo de la red social a
las noticias en el país oceánico y tras
unas negociaciones entre la compañía y
el gobierno australiano la norma es
ahora una realidad por weiwei es miren
hemos legislado ha tenido un efecto muy
significativo con acuerdos anunciados
entre tanto entre google y una variedad
de empresas de medios de noticias
australianas y ahora facebook y al menos
una empresa de medios de noticias
australiana dannii smer y facebook antes
de ser aprobada el parlamento hizo el
martes pasado una serie de enmiendas
técnicas al proyecto de ley presentado
en diciembre de 2020 las enmiendas
fueron producto de diálogos entre la red
social y el gobierno la legislación
obliga a la justa contraprestación e
incluso establece que en caso de no
llegar a un acuerdo comercial se hará la
intervención de un panel de arbitraje
del gobierno para fijar el monto
claramente las compañías de medios más
grandes serán las beneficiarias
iniciales de las negociaciones para
evitar
efectivamente las disposiciones de
arbitraje en el código el tiempo y así
los actores más pequeños tienen acceso a
fondos importantes
la ley de pagos fue creada a raíz de
estudios de la comisión australiana de
competencia y consumo en este se reflejó
el desequilibrio en los ingresos
publicitarios entre las compañías
tecnológicas y los medios de
comunicación países como canadá reino
unido francia o india han mostrado
interés en la elaboración de una ley
similar en sus territorios